et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Stéphane de folle bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ma socialiste du monde
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par Julien
Lecuyer de la Voix du Nord bonjour
Julien bonjour monsieur le folle la Voix
du Nord la Voix du Nord
la Voix du Nord
les élections américaines puisque le
résultat est incertain pour le moment
l'avantage et du côté des républicains
Donald Trump c'est d'ailleurs félicité
des chiffres et la très vite pile la
parole qu'elles enseignements vous
pouvez en tirer est-ce que la sociale
démocratie version Joe Biden est en
panne face à la montée des populismes et
du populisme de Donald Trump
la montée des populismes elle est
partout je pars revenir sur les
élections au Brésil regarde ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis et l'Europe est là
aussi pour montrer cette montée des
populistes avec un conservatisme et une
logique identitaire qui s'affirme dans
beaucoup de pays dans un doute sur
l'avenir parce que c'est ça la question
pour une grande partie de ce que
j'appelle les couches insécurisées elles
sont insécurisées au présent elles sont
insécurisées vis-à-vis de l'avenir et
c'est ça qui fait que il y a une
coagulation entre un conservatisme
identitaire et
couche populaire qui trouve là une
manière d'exprimer à la fois une colère
et surtout un doute et une peur ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième la
social-démocratie et la seule force
politique aujourd'hui qui résiste ou qui
existe face au populisme je suis désolé
de le rappeler que ça soit au Danemark
il y a pas longtemps que ça soit en
Allemagne c'est encore un autre sujet
parce que l'Allemagne est une exception
aujourd'hui en Europe que ça soit en
Italie même si les scores sont pas à la
hauteur c'est pas la gauche radicale qui
existe ou qui résiste c'est pas cette
gauche j'allais dire j'avais ciste pose
porter et poussé par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui résiste dans le monde et en Europe
aujourd'hui ça c'est le deuxième
enseignement le troisième c'est qu'elle
résiste parce que malgré tout ce qui
nous est annoncé c'était un raz-de-marée
ce n'est pas un raz-de-marée et
peut-être que je l'espère une démocrate
garderont le Sénat mais ce n'est pas un
raz-de-marée ça veut dire que cette
gauche sociale démocrate elle est pas
parfaite elle fait face à une montée du
populisme mais c'est la seule force
politique organisée qui résiste et si je
reviens quelques leçons nationales par
rapport et en France en France est-ce
que c'est d'association démocratique
elle n'existe plus elle est passée
derrière Jean-Luc Mélenchon elle est à
réinventer en France elle est à
réinventé totalement c'est bien le débat
qui n'aura pas lieu je vous rassure au
Parti socialiste aujourd'hui parce que
c'est parti et dans l'incapacité de se
rénover de se renouveler
évidemment de la gauche on y vient tout
de suite puisque vous publiez une
tribune dans l'Obs pourquoi on a tué ma
gauche
qui est souvent passé tout un processus
post quinquennat de Hollande qui a fait
que en réaction
à l'échec qui a été celui de la fronde
et d'un quinquennat ou le président
sortant ne s'est pas représenté parce
que c'est comme ça le point de départ de
toute la dédices du socialisme français
du socialisme démocratique français et
qui a conduit un certain nombre d'élus à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste a
considéré que la vraie page a tourné
c'était celle de ce quinquennat Hollande
mais quand même temps qu'on vous la
tournée au lieu d'essayer de se repenser
ils ont été chercher les solutions chez
d'autres
les Verts au début rappelez-vous Olivier
Faure à Blois avant les élections
municipales ou après les élections
municipales c'était l'Alliance et bien
ça peut être un écologiste ou
associaliste puis après la
présidentielle où c'est imposé le choix
d'adine algo fait par Olivier Faure et
le résultat que l'on sait ça a été le
choix de la nuque pèse
voilà et on s'est rangé aujourd'hui
derrière Jean-Luc Mélenchon
politiquement celui qui mène le débat
politique à gauche c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la France insoumise à part
venir mais ici ça a été suffisamment
rappelé discuté sur la motion de censure
la manière dont tout ça est conduit
celui qui fixe la ligne et j'en veux
pour preuve l'image qui m'est restée de
cette grande marche d'un dimanche
après-midi ou sur un plateau de ou une
remorque de camions c'était Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a rangé la foule et
Olivier fort qui était derrière mais
Monsieur le en fait bon je vais vous
parler de pourquoi on a tué ma gauche
vous appelez à fonder un nouveau
mouvement on a vu que vous aviez soutenu
aussi le manifeste de Bernard Cazeneuve
est-ce que concrètement vous estimez que
le PS est un astre mort et qu'il faut
construire complètement autre chose mais
je pense que le c'est pas le PS en tant
que partie apparaît qui est un astre
mort c'est une PS en tant que valeur et
penser politique qui est un instrument
Olivier Faure n'étant que j'ai dire la
l'élément qui fédère tous ceux qui
derrière pense que c'est la bonne ligne
qui pour des intérêts je le dis dans la
tribune locaux pense que l'alliance à
gauche va leur permettre de continuer à
exister alors que les municipales comme
les régionales ont montré que ceux qui
avaient réussi n'était pas forcément
ceux qui faisait des alliances je pense
à Carole Delga je pense à Loïc chez les
Girard en Bretagne ça a été des lignes
d'affirmation politique qui ont conduit
à des victoires alors la logique des
sortants jouant aujourd'hui
un rôle très important
ce qui va se passer par la suite je
préviens tout de suite c'est 10
solutions et cette tête étouffement de
la sociale démocratie ou du socialisme
démocratique français c'est un risque
pour tous ceux qui localement pensent
encore aujourd'hui garder leur siège
demain mais vous pensez vous pensez
concrètement pour répondre peut-être à
ma question que il y a un avenir à
l'intérieur du PS ou est-ce qu'il faut
créer une nouvelle entité moi je pense
que le PS on verra probablement à
l'occasion de ce congrès va avoir un mal
fou à se rénover parce qu'il y a une
espèce de logique qui consiste à ne pas
pouvoir sortir de cette stratégie
d'alliance et d'effacement qui va
conduire l'étouffement donc il faut
essayer pour éviter d'être étouffer
d'ouvrir le débat à l'extérieur du Parti
socialiste parce que le bilan d'olive
avec probablement un mouvement d'abord
et puis un parti qui peut si le
mouvement est suffisamment fort pour
s'adresser aux Français fait bouger les
lignes et on refonde un parti social la
liste français avec la belle histoire du
socialisme français quand je vois par
exemple que la référence au Front
Populaire a été prise par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est oublier que Léon Blum au
congrès de Tours et celui qui avait dit
je vais garder la vieille maison quand
vous partirez à l'aventure je vais
regarder la vieille maison celui qui a
résisté dans la ligne et les valeurs de
la sociale démocratie française du
socialisme démocratique français c'est
le houblon de le voir récupérer par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et une gauche
radicale c'est un retournement de
l'histoire ou une appréciation
complètement fausse de l'histoire on
doit donc retrouver cette ligne et il
faut la reconstruire sachant que la
social-démocratie française a aussi à se
réinventer sur beaucoup de sujets la
question d'écologie ça n'a jamais été
fondamentalement un vrai problème qui a
été intégré dans la sociale démocratie
française les premiers à avoir intégré
l'écologie dans la réflexion et la
pensée sociale démocrate sont les bien
en particulier avec Harlem
grosbrouckland dès 86 qui pose la
question du développement durable comme
la combinaison de trois grands facteurs
l'écologie l'économie et le social nous
on a traîné beaucoup trop longtemps pour
penser ce genre de sujet donc il faut se
repenser et dans ce débat je pense juste
la question de l'écologie voyez bien que
entre une écologie radicale radicalisée
avec Sandrine Rousseau ou une écologie
réformiste qu'on doit inventer et qui
combine écologie économie et sociale il
y a un espace politique qui n'est pas
occupé aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que pense
le Parti socialiste sur la question de
la croissance la décroissance la
sobriété de l'investissement de
l'éco-canédianisme comme je le pense et
comme je les théorisé rien pourriez-vous
poser la question il vous répondra on
est ni pour la croissance ni pour la
décroissance donc on est pour rien
Stéphane Le follet le fait est que pour
reprendre des propos de d'Olivier Faure
dont on a compris que il était pas
forcément votre meilleur ami
le premier Premier secrétaire je l'ai
connu il était directeur adjo non mais
je sais c'est politique vous êtes connu
avec François Hollande en effet vous
avez vous avez eu le même combat sauf
qu'aujourd'hui le premier secretaire
Olivier Faure il dit débat est simple
d'un côté il y a Hollande et de l'autre
moi se tourner le passe vers le passé ou
avancer vous êtes l'homme du passé alors
l'homme du passif mais quel est le quel
est le bilan d'Olivier fort c'est
impassible regardons les élections
puisque on juge un premier secrétaire et
un parti politique sur ces résultats
électoraux campagne des européennes
choix d'effacer une partie socialiste et
de mettre la tête de la liste André
kluxmann et place publique Raphaël
Raphaël et place publique oui j'avais
oublié son prénom
ce qui va faire d'ailleurs quitter le
bureau national du Parti socialiste à ce
moment-là parce que je me suis dit ça y
est c'est parti
6% quand vous regardez les municipales
et les régionales est-ce que la ligne
qui a été celle prenez par Olivier Faure
et celle qui a gagné à Marseille
probablement c'est la seule fois où
espèce de mouvement de rassemblement
arrive à gagner une ville dans une
situation où l'ergoda se terminant il y
avait un besoin de changement mais si je
prends Montpellier par exemple ligne de
la fosse grande ville française gagnée
sur quelle ligne politique l'affirmation
il était seul au départ il a fini par
gagner la ville de Montpellier les
municipales c'est d'abord des élections
qui ont été gagnées localement si je
prends les régionales je j'évoquais tout
à l'heure les régionales vous avez deux
régions la Bretagne et l'Occitanie c'est
radicalement et
orthogan orthogonale à la ligne de
Livier fort puisque que ça soit Carole
deliga ou le Girard ont affirmé une
ligne socialiste sans les sans la France
insoumise et que pour ce qui était
d'ailleurs de même du Grand Est du
centre il y avait une ligne au départ
sans les verres
et ils ont gagné ils ont maintenu en
tant que sortant ses régions donc ça
n'avait rien à voir régional tout le
monde a gagné en tout cas on a maintenu
les mêmes régions d'ailleurs qu'on avait
gagné avec François Hollande très bien
est-ce que c'est de la responsabilité ou
la ligne de olive et fort non par
définition c'est pas sa ligne après il y
a la présidentielle qu'est-ce qui a été
fait avant la présidentielle pour avoir
un travail de fond à un débat j'étais
venu ici d'ailleurs et j'en remercie
toujours Public Sénat c'est le seul
endroit où j'ai pu demander un débat
j'ai écrit un livre et ce qu'il y a eu
un débat est-ce qu'il y a eu une
discussion est-ce qu'on a été capable de
regarder la France telle qu'elle était
pour essayer de penser un projet
socialiste non il y a eu une décision
qui consiste à dire faut soutenir à
l'hidalgo résultat 1,7
puis après on a inventé la nupesse mais
qui est d'abord un bon résultat pour qui
en termes de députés pour la France
insoumise on est revenu avec à peu près
le même nombre de députés qu'on avait
avant quand on était que socialiste donc
c'est pas un résultat qui est à mettre
au à l'actif d'Olivier fort donc c'est
un passif pour reprendre une belle
formule vous êtes peut-être
du passif vous avez vous avez donc un
congrès fin janvier où il va il va y
avoir en effet une bataille entre
plusieurs lignes est-ce que vous
concrètement vous vous allez vous êtes
attiré par par une certaine voie on a vu
qu'une troisième voie était en
construction avec Carole Delga signé par
an hidalgos signé aussi par le maire de
Montpellier Michael Delafosse est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait vous
attirer
j'attends que elle donne son choix j'ai
pas l'impression qu'aujourd'hui elle les
fait encore même si pendant les
législatives elle a été claire et elle a
choisi de ne pas être dans la nupesse au
moment des législatives donc maintenant
je j'attendrai qu'elle donne sa ligne
moi je ne change rien elle
a dit
Bolivie Macron il y a une large place
c'est grosso modo ce que vous dites dans
votre tribune bon vous êtes sur la même
ligne non seulement
ne pas vous alliez on a l'impression que
vous êtes sur la même ligne avec un
Zelda
depuis le début la seule qui avant le
congrès de Villeurbanne pendant le congé
de Villeurbanne a tenu Link était celle
de l'opposition à la ligne de d'Olivier
fort c'était Hélène Geoffroy donc je
peux pas non plus faire comme si ça
n'existait pas mais est-ce que vous
allez prendre position parce que là il y
a trois lignes il y a la ligne Olivier
fort la ligne Hélène Geoffroy et cette
troisième fois mais quelle est la ligne
refont
ation moi je voudrais qu'on me donne une
lecture politique pas simplement sur les
noms politiques de la ligne de
refondation hier soir il paraît qu'il y
a eu un conseil national avec une
contribution de celui qui était le
premier célibataire là Mayer Rossignol
bon il a dit il y a un symptôme de Noël
le maire de Rouen il y a 72 choses mais
quelle est leur ligne si c'est la ligne
de la présidentielle avec Anne Hidalgo
enfin
je vais pas vous dire que je
n'anticipe pas le résultat il faut
repenser cette ligne politiquement c'est
ça le sujet c'est pas simplement une
question de personne moi ce que j'ai
envie de dire c'est que avant
de choisir une ligne même si par exemple
sur la question laïque sur la question
de la sécurité et globalement sur les
questions d'après ce que j'ai compris
des prises de position de Michael de la
fosse et je l'ai cité d'ailleurs dans ma
tribune je suis plutôt sur cette ligne
où il est plutôt sur la ligne que j'ai
défendu depuis 4 ans 5 ans sans boire
être entendu donc c'est ça qu'il faut
discuter c'est ça
le temps des contributions on va pas
embêter les gens ça va arriver fin
novembre je crois on va passer aux
motion donc là c'est un vote je prendrai
position mais moi ce que je pense c'est
qu'avant de laisser penser que c'est
dans le Parti socialiste que ça va
tranché il faut qu'on ouvre un débat à
l'extérieur du Parti social et sous
quelle forme qu'est-ce que vous faites
la nupette elle existe et vous savez
qu'on peut être adhérent de la nupesse
et adhérent du parti socialiste il y a
une bille appartenance ce matin c'est ce
qu'a voulu Olivier fort bah écoutez ce
qu'il faut essayer de faire
c'est de rassembler des gens qui sur une
autre ligne que celle que la nuit pêche
aujourd'hui puisse porter des valeurs et
des idées et un projet
pas vous de quitter le parti socialiste
non est-ce que puisque vous parlez d'un
mouvement qui doit se créer à
l'extérieur de partie socialiste est-ce
que vous souhaitez être à la tête de ce
mouvement honnête le moteur je suis pas
là pour me dire je vais être à la tête
de ce mouvement
parce que il y a aussi Bernard
Cazeneuve
pourrait mener ce mouvement est-ce que
vous le souhaitez
proposer un manifeste qui a plus de 5000
signatures je l'ai signé puisque sur le
fond c'est un rappel des valeurs et des
grands engagements de la social
démocratie et de ce qui nous différencie
aujourd'hui de la gauche radicale c'est
ça le sujet donc ça c'est un point
d'appui très important et c'est bien sûr
avec Bernard Cazeneuve qu'on doit
travailler ensemble moi j'ai pas à
revendiquer une position même si je
revendique et depuis longtemps et tout
ce que j'ai écrit que ça soit dans mon
livre ou que ça soit sur tous les textes
que j'écris vous aviez celui du point
qui disait que je préférais la France
ambitieuse à la France insoumise j'ai
écrit j'ai une pensée qui est maintenant
très claire et moi ce que je souhaite
c'est l'affirmer et donc je verrai avec
Bernard Cazeneuve ce qu'il souhaite
faire mais en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne moi je suis décidé à porter ce
débat maintenant à l'extérieur du la
partie socialiste et là vous restez
socialiste on a bien compris est-ce que
vous le resterez si Olivier fort
remporte le congrès de Marseille fin
janvier mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui de
Marseille tel qu'il est parti devrait
donner une
confirmation probable d'Olivier Faure
qu'est-ce que ça change pour moi depuis
5 ans moi je vais maintenant mener un
débat je le répète à l'intérieur du
parti socialiste avec ceux qui sont sur
une ligne de contestation de ligne
d'Olivier fort et à l'extérieur voilà
c'est ça la ligne maintenant pour moi
après avec une préparation et un
objectif des élections européennes parce
que leur là dans l'Europe d'aujourd'hui
avoir la ligne de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est pas seulement un désaccord de fond
politique
sur l'instant c'est un désaccord de fond
comment dirais-je fondamental sur
l'histoire du socialisme et celle en
particulier de François Mitterrand et
Pierre Mauroy dont on inauguré une rue
Hyères sur l'histoire du socialisme
européen et en fonction des grands défis
qui sont posés à au monde et à la
planète aujourd'hui être dans la logique
de la désobéissance à l'échelle
européenne pour c'est un désaccord mais
total donc la question des européennes
si c'est pour faire ce que j'ai entendu
d'ailleurs de la part de la direction du
Parti socialiste encore une liste
d'union avec le programme de la nupes et
j'invite chacun à relire toujours les
textes c'est toujours intéressant de
s'apercevoir de ce qui est dit c'est non
mais dans ces cas-là Stéphane Le folle
si il y a un accord en vue des
européennes PS et les filles est-ce que
vous présenterez vous vous irez avec une
liste autonome il faut absolument se
mettre dans la situation d'avoir une
liste si c'est cette perspective qui est
en train de se dessiner c'est très clair
pour moi là on n'est pas sur des sujets
puisque vous restez au sein du PS ou là
vous l'aurez quitté sinon
est-ce que ça sera la goutte de trop
tropines c'était marqué à plusieurs
reprises pour moi c'est pas la goutte de
trop c'est ce qui fait que à ce
moment-là il y a une rupture et donc il
faut se préparer
aux élections européennes à cette
rupture je sais pas ce qui se passera on
va attendre les résultats du Congrès et
on verra que peut-être tactiquement
encore une fois il y aura des espèces de
de flou qui vont s'organiser mais ça
doit être
un engagement fort
potentiel de rupture et du listes autre
que celle que pourrait présenter le
Parti socialiste avec parce que c'est ça
le sujet la France insoumise en tête de
liste parce que c'est comme ça le la
perspective qui nous est offerte et
quand ouvert j'attendrai et de regarder
ce qui va se passer au Congrès parce
qu'on voit bien que là aussi il y a une
fracture entre la ligne de la radicalité
incarnez par Sandrine Rousseau et une
forme de réformisme écologiste à la
grunen incarner aujourd'hui peu ou proue
par Yannick Jadot qu'est-ce que ça va
donner ou va tomber l'écologie politique
française en tout cas celle qui fixe
pour le coup encore une fois une partie
de la ligne politique de l'expression
publique de l'écologie aujourd'hui
politique c'est Sandrine Rousseau ce
n'est pas ma ligne ce départ
il pourrait se faire avec lui bien sûr
avec les réformistes écologistes bien
entendu c'est bien la question parce que
regardez ce qui se passe en Allemagne je
disais que c'était une exception
l'Allemagne c'est que l'Allemagne a fait
une coalition Grünen social-démocrate et
libéraux
européenne écologiste et en même temps
sérieuse sur la question des finances
publiques ils ont créé cette coalition
qui a fait baisser faut quand même s'en
rendre compte
l'extrême gauche dit que
et de manière extrêmement forte et
l'extrême droite surtout l'extrême
droite ce que vous nous dites c'est que
dans le la perspective de 2027 si on ne
résout pas cette équation du de la
gauche bolivarienne peu importe gauche
si on occupe pas cet espace du centre
gauche finalement c'est un boulevard
pour Marine Le Pen et c'est ce que je
pense c'est ce que j'ai écrit c'est que
à la fin aux fin du fin et on le voit et
là on revient aux élections américaines
on revient oser aux élections au brexit
en Grande-Bretagne le risque c'est que
cette radicalité qui s'incarne sur la
partie progressiste sur la gauche et
comme réaction politique et bien la
radicalité de la droite et de l'extrême
droite c'est bien ça le sujet c'est que
la démocratie fonctionne aussi avec ça
toujours été critiqué et souvent
contesté mais ce qui fait l'enjeu pour
un pays une nation de garder une unité
et un rassemblement c'est qu'il y ait
des gens modérés qui soit capable de
porter des idées et des valeurs mais qui
soit ensuite capable de rassembler et de
gouverner quand vous radicalisez les
positions vous polarisez les grandes
questions politiques et le risque c'est
la fracture monsieur le folle justement
une question le Emmanuel Macron a lancé
un appel au bonne volonté pour un accord
de gouvernement il a visé les LR mais
est-ce que les députés PS ne devraient
pas s'interroger aussi sur un accord de
gouvernement pour essayer de j'allais
dire de sauver les de sauver les meubles
et peut-être d'éviter à la au
rassemblement national d'arriver en 2027
le problème d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que
il a engagé son deuxième mandat dans un
flou qui est encore autant le en même
temps du premier mandat et avec l'idée
de la réussite de la jeunesse à entraîné
politiquement en se disant on va sortir
des vieilles tambouilles et des vieilles
marmites il y a une jeune qui arrive il
y a cette idée de la réussite tipi au
fur et à mesure du premier quinquennat
déjà et là sur le deuxième on voit bien
que il n'y a plus véritablement de Cape
ni de lignes politiques et que
globalement le tournant vers la droite
est en train d'être pris d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron on l'a dit clairement il
tend la main aux républicains et dans sa
propre majorité aujourd'hui les gens
politiquesment qui pèsent Bruno Le Maire
Gérald Darmanin sont des gens de droite
bon donc il y a et c'est ce qui fait que
les républicains ça puent comment se
positionner face à la fin du macronisme
tel qu'il a été pensé au moment de 2017
parce que c'est ça qui est en train de
se passer il faut repenser une sociale
démocratie française capable d'apporter
des messages de progrès pour tout le
monde et de reconquérir une partie de
l'électorat populaire en même temps
qu'elle est sur un socle qui va garder
c'est électorat
démocratique encore présente à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'elle
doit
être plus conciliante est-ce qu'elle
doit trouver les moyens de d'accorder
ces violons avec le gouvernement on voit
bien que la ligne qui est défendue par
Olivier fort et Boris Vallot ou
aujourd'hui
Marc aussi des fractures au sein même du
groupe socialiste c'est que on est dans
un entre deux aujourd'hui où va aller la
décision vers qui doit-on aller vous
avez vu que sur la deuxième motion de
censure va lire à beau par exemple les
six autres députés ont refusé de la
voter quand le président du groupe et
Olivier fort on continuait à voter la
deuxième fois la motion de censure
sachant que le RN a voté et qu'il a
fallu attendre la troisième fois avec ce
que a dit ce député eren qui n'a fait
que rappeler des positions qu'avaient le
rassemblement national pour dire ah ben
non là on la voit plus mais cette
question va revenir
donc au sein du groupe socialiste
puisque vous parlez à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a déjà des tensions
politiques qui émergent elles sont
comment dirais-je extrêmement petite en
termes de portée politique mais elle
existe déjà donc si on baisse pas
politiquement pour emmener justement un
groupe qui déjà doute de sa position et
bien on y arrivera pas et c'est pour ça
que je pense que c'est non seulement en
interne du Parti socialiste qu'il faut
le faire mais c'est aussi à l'extérieur
du Parti Social un dernier mot sur un
tout autre sujet Stéphane folle puisque
sort aujourd'hui un film documentaire
mission régénération sur la route
cruciale du sol pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique vous y
apparaissez vous nous en dites un petit
mot
des acteurs et des actrices américaines
il a fait que les Américains viennent en
France on la COP 21 pour signaler que la
France et son ministre de l'Agriculture
de l'époque sur les sols et le stockage
de carbone avait pris de l'avance à
l'échelle mondiale est-ce que vous avez
entendu parler un jour
Olivier Faure et la direction du Parti
socialiste de l'agroécologie jamais
est-ce que vous voyez quelques
publicités aujourd'hui en particulier de
Terre solidaire sur le développement de
l'agroécologie est-ce que la question du
carbone et du stockage par la
photosynthèse et les vers de terre que
j'avais porté quand j'étais ministre
avec une loi qui avait été votée par les
socialistes par les communistes par les
écologistes par les centristes et
l'abstention des républicains à l'époque
et défendu par le Parti socialiste
aujourd'hui non faut que ça soit les
Américains plutôt démocrates puisqu'ils
viennent de Californie voilà donc moi je
suis très fier de ce film et j'invite
tout le monde à aller le voir pour
comprendre en plus à la méthode
américaine c'est à dire que c'est une
forme de vulgarisation d'une question
technique liée à la photosynthèse
magnifique film donc j'en fais la
promotion c'est le seul film que j'ai
dans lequel j'ai tourné donc au début
d'une nouvelle carrière c'est ça que je
voulais dire c'est pas encore non
peut-être mission de génération ça
s'appelle et ça sort aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup Stéphane d'avoir été la Une de
La Voix du Nord c'est aussi le climat de
l'environnement gaz à effet de serre des
milliards pour inciter à la
décarbonation
dans le Nord-Pas-de-Calais où on a huit
des industries les plus polluantes de
France donc on va dire que exactement
merci Julien merci Stéphane
mais j'étais ici j'avais déjà dit ce que
je pensais je me rappelle que les fameux
fun
le débat sur les bases j'étais venu ici
et je vous avais expliqué qu'avant
d'aller imaginer qu'on va faire du
stockage d'eau partout il faut avoir des
pratiques qui évitent de faire évaporer
l'eau du sol ça c'est le principe de
base et j'entends pas assez le
Gouvernement sur ce sujet allez voir le
film et vous comprendrez
Stéphane Le folle on passe au club
détails
[Musique]